je suis désolé mais on sent qu'il ya un
problème avec vos papiers qui a été le
souci avec mon passeport
nous avons trouvé un autre paul dedalus
alors tu es tu je ne sais plus souvent
que c'est pas pareil je cultive mon
mystère mystérieux tu parles tu fais
attention sur les attentes
tapas leicester était dans la classe de
ma soeur paule savent pas de te manger
des yeux je fais toujours cet effet là
pourquoi ce que fait exceptionnel
c'est qu'ils sont ils tu le connais non
qu'elle s'accompagne il souvenu pour te
casser la gueule en sorte avec esther
désolé mais je crois que tu es bientôt
bourdeilles toi je crois que tu l'as gaz
même moi je connais pas et déjà tu
m'agace un peu
tout est effacé sinon 3,4 bribes
je veux pas d'un fainéant dans ma maison
me rapporte pas de telles notes
est ce que quelqu'un t'a déjà aimé plus
que sa vie moi je voudrais aimer comme
ça
papa qui parce je fais esther tu existes
tellement fort comme une montagne
si tu existes c'est à dire que je ne
suis pas enfermée dans un rêve
je crois que j'ai un peu merdé avec
leicester comment ça je crois qu'on a un
peu couché ensemble
non tu t'installes dans ma chambre tu
couches avec ma femme elle ne t'en fais
pas l aime que toi
je voulais désiré et je crois que
leicester aussi à sa manière à désirer
plus notre liaison nous connaissions
mais de fou maintenant elle est avec moi
elle est avec du jeu ont changé
un joujou chute donner une identité
je sais plus si je suis bon moi je sais
que viendra y
je confirme je me souviens